ضحايا تحت الانقاض بالفعل عده مناطق
استهدفت في نفس الوقت هنا سقطت اكثر من
عشره صواريخ من نوع جراد بينما سقطت ايضا
زخات مماثله في احياء اخرى القصف متبادل
خالد ما بين الطرفين الطرف الروسي والطرف
الاوكراني تقول الدفاع الروسيه والسلطات
هنا بانهم يستهدفون منصات الصواريخ
والقواعد العسكريه التي تستهدف المدنيين
هنا في دانيس كما ان العمليات العسكريه
الروسيه مستمره للسيطره اكثر على اراضي
حول المقاطعه في الاتجاهات الجنوبيه
والشماليه الحديث عن باخمت
وايضا مدن اخرى في الجنوب حول ماريوبل
وفالنافاخا بالفعل هناك معارك ضاريه في
مدينتي
يصعد جيش الروسي لقصف مدينه لم يتمكن من
دخوله لكن يسعى لقصفها بقوه بالمدافع
والصواريخ من اجل اقتحامها تنفذ عمليات
اقتحامات اوليه بشكل يومي من اجل التقدم
في المحور الشمالي الغربي ايضا هنا نرى
يعني رجال
وزاره الطوارئ عمال الطوارئ يعملون من اجل
البحث عن ناجين في هذه
البنايه التي تم استهدافها من قبل
الصواريخ التي تقول روسيا بانها صواريخ
اوكرانيه تستهدف المدنيين